Ustedes han denominado la muerte Cruzada
como un autogolpe que crea una situación
de dictaduras Sin embargo es un
movimiento constitucional porque está
tan fuerte crítica Y qué es lo que temen
Sí muy buenas
precisamente nosotros vemos como una
acto de estas características porque es
una respuesta desesperada del gobierno
nacional al saber que existían los votos
para su destitución recordemos que el
día de ayer empezó el proceso de juicio
político que debía continuar hoy con la
deliberación en la asamblea nacional y
el día sábado se iba a votar por la
destitución del presidente de la
república el presidente de la república
al verse pues acorralado y que
prácticamente no tenía los votos
suficientes para salvarse la destitución
acude a este mecanismo de manera
sorpresiva inesperada pues y todo eso ha
dado mucho que hablar por la disolución
del Congreso que se acaba de dar a
partir de la firma del decreto bueno Y
ustedes preparan movilizaciones para
estos próximos días y bajo qué
exigencias
bueno aún no se ha tomado una decisión
final de movilizarse se ha resuelto
consultar a cada una de nuestras
estructuras a nivel organizativo sobre
todo en cada uno de los territorios
mantener asambleas de permanentes en los
territorios para definir los mecanismos
las acciones que puedan tomarse la
decisión que se ha tomado desde el
movimiento indígena
Y si el plazo que o sea a largo plazo el
presidente no atendiera sus demandas
verían también ustedes quizás la
posibilidad de viajar hasta la capital
del país para protestar bueno sin duda
se caracteriza por su nivel de respuesta
ante medidas que puedan tornarse
antipopulares en este caso lo que sí
hemos dejado muy claro es que en estos
meses que tiene el presidente todavía va
a estar en funciones hasta que se
convoque las elecciones en caso de que
se emita algún tipo de decreto que sea
contrario a los intereses populares
principalmente en temas como el
extractivismo entre otros por supuesto
inmediatamente se activarían
movilizaciones